in democracies leaders need the votes of
millions of people pleasing so many
people is incredibly difficult
so democracies offer voters public
policy options in exchange for votes but
in dictatorships leaders only need the
loyalty of a select few
so they purchase it with cash sports
cars or luxury real estate all
dictatorships are to some degree
corruption fuelled kleptocracy this is
bad news for democracy the rule of law
and free markets to protect their stolen
wealth kleptocrats abuse anonymous
financial tools in Western democracies
and hire Westerners to help them do it
so how can we dismantle the ways in
which corrupt dictatorships abuse the
virtues of democracy and capitalism we
can attack kleptocracy by leveraging our
comparative advantages in transparency
and the rule of law a key first step
would be to do away with the anonymous
shell company a commonly used tool for
facilitating international corruption to
fight kleptocracy we must consolidate
Liberty where it already exists and lead
the way to greater freedom and
prosperity around the world what do you
think America should do to deal with
authoritarian corruption let us know in
our poll also let us know what other
topics you'd like our scholars to cover
in 60 seconds and be sure to LIKE and
subscribe for more research and videos
from AEI